is it big mike from across the street
nah nah that's monica the transfer
big mike what's happening lisa yeah i
had a good weekend i watched blazing
shadows with paula for the first it was
her first time watching it did she enjoy
it yeah that holds up
for me it does for her but yeah i i told
my mom that we watched it today and
she's like oh when you're kids it's good
for girls but it's always good for guys
but girls don't always get it but i i
still love that bean scene and farting
love to be able to meet him he's [ __ ]
i like my silent film mel brooks guy
this yeah thumbs great i still haven't
seen the american history part one or
history of the world part one that's a
good one
you know there's just so many movies
that you want to see and now with
netflix
i'm behind the [ __ ] catalog
because me i want to start from scratch
all over again you know i did watch a
[ __ ] great movie this week
you know man as a
movie guy or whatever the [ __ ] we are we
like to watch entertainment
and i've read scripts and the scripts
that get made that you look at and go
this is [ __ ] total garbage yeah i
really want to see the script for rocky
because every
time i watch the movie it gets better
and better it's not something i had the
dvd somewhere in the house
it's not something that if i'm [ __ ]
lonely and the power's out and i gotta
watch a dvd
i would put in because in your mind
you've watched rocky a thousand times
right it's like a [ __ ] relative
rocky is like a parent
you take it for granted until you watch
it even with commercials and you pick up
little things that you go you know what
as dumb and [ __ ] goofy as he is for
that [ __ ] movie sylvester stallone on
that day was einstein oh yeah so all the
stars came together i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll go pound for pound
that day
when he shot that move i couldn't even
contain my tears
i could not
contain my tears the emotion it brought
back to me like where i was when i
watched it the first time i was at the
union city cinema and i saw a theater
for the first time in my life i saw a
theater blow up
and then a year later i saw a theater
blow up again with the original longest
yard i never saw that in the movie
theater white people [ __ ] on their
chairs cheering for convicts
you're walking home as a kid going why
was i cheering for [ __ ] convicts
these are the bad people but the whole
theater was on their feet but just going
back to rocky it's perfect it's hard for
a guy like me because when i saw it
there's other ones like it there's other
boxing movies well and whatever i don't
know what year came out whatever came
out was there anything else like it at
all or was this the secret here it came
out
how'd it be 73 or 76 one of those two
[ __ ] years
76 okay later on when you're not doing
nothing i want all you [ __ ] to
see what was nominated for what was the
nominee for academy awards in 76 let me
teach you a [ __ ] lesson about movies
so your [ __ ] head explodes okay
should i do 76 or 77. well whatever the
[ __ ] 76 and 77 do the split screen what
are you got 19 computers for the [ __ ]
could be a weatherman
what was nominated that year for academy
award okay your head will spin best
picture
was
rocky one all pr all the president's men
bound for glory network and taxi driver
are you [ __ ] kidding me
there's four movies in that well let's
we them again read them again rocky okay
all the president's men okay bound for
glory down fool bound for glory [ __ ]
them
network which i don't that's the only
one network is tremendous and taxi
driver okay what do you think
what the [ __ ] do you think what the [ __ ]
do you think now let's get the release
date for taxi driver and let's get the
release date for rocky taxi driver was
also 76 let me see if i'm on the date
okay so you're a [ __ ] young kid
february 8th
you're 10 years old what was what's that
one taxi drivers february february 8th
19 1976. which one else which other one
do you want i'm rocky rocky
december 3rd of 76. okay so you thought
i'm sorry november 21st you think about
that that was a thanksgiving movie in
those days now what do you go see for
thanksgiving
dick
rocky for thanksgiving you everybody
listen if you're not if you weren't born
or you want a lot it was [ __ ] huge
everybody was rocky and everybody was
doing jumping jacks everybody was
running in the streets everybody was
drinking [ __ ] eggs brawl
everybody you know everybody who wanted
to be a tough guy was i just ate 19 eggs
raw the barbarian brothers were eating
36 eggs now you went to see taxi driver
the impact that movie [ __ ] made on me
as a kid i remember that movie came on
abc's sunday night movie
october of 79 taxi driver taxi driver
that's the first time i [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] shoes well they
cut a lot of [ __ ] out in those days but
i remember watching in my mom's bedroom
and my head was gonna [ __ ] blow up
like
these movies would just put back to
rocky that scene when he goes in
to the guy and the guy says i want you
to do this this this and this
and he goes listen
i'm just a [ __ ] hammer [ __ ]
i almost had a nervous breakdown right
there in my chair my wife had to [ __ ]
give me mountain milk
and then the scene when he goes to look
at the thing and he sees his shorts are
red instead of blue
he tells the guy and he goes does it
really matter anyway
and then he goes back to the room with
adrian and he tells her he just wants to
go the distance
so he's he's he doesn't end up like one
of the bums in the neighborhood
are you [ __ ] kidding me guys
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i don't want my head i almost i i i
almost had to [ __ ] take 15 volumes
did you have that experience when you
first started or because of looking back
on it now you just look at that and go
that's how i felt i understand what he
felt like he just didn't want to be a
bum from the [ __ ] neighborhood just
end up in a bar drinking
talking about playing high school
football or whatever the [ __ ] they talk
about those people
that's [ __ ] crazy have you seen the
preview for creed
no they say it's spectacular i haven't
seen it it looks interesting yeah just
tilt it down a little bit sorry
there we go better yeah when you
p people think it looks good i just
looking just seeing all these remakes i
just wish it would stop but if it looks
good then
i guess well cream this is a remake it's
it's just it's the last in the rocky
chain
okay you know so it's the sixth [ __ ]
movie he's put out obviously the studios
wouldn't invest in it they don't think
they're going to get their change back
because obviously rocky and [ __ ]
china they throw new chucks in the movie
they [ __ ] like dragons on fire that's
the you know that's what we know what we
don't know what they do here we don't
know what they do with england and
[ __ ] you know look at the guy from
baywatch wasn't he huge in germany
that's awesome yeah we don't [ __ ]
know what these people are doing they
said that the reason why netflix did
that like six movie deal with sandler
was because of how well he does overseas
yeah like that's like they're like we
don't care if they're watching in
america this is for yeah in the
philippines they're still [ __ ]
talking about you know him on a
skateboard or whatever the [ __ ] adam
sandler does so you never [ __ ] know
mike the agent yes sir
i really wanted to talk to you about
comedy tonight this is an education type
thing because this is a question that
every comedian has
and if anybody knows the answer you're
the [ __ ] king of this [ __ ] i know
we've discussed it with ari you know we
are all dear friends we've known each
other
for a long time you know mike the
[ __ ] agent yeah we've met many times
yeah mike's a good [ __ ] dude so
that's more of an education type podcast
you know i got hit up by a bunch of
people
about this nick diaz thing plain and
simple right okay plain and [ __ ]
simple
you could fight on the street corner
you could fight in the [ __ ] gym on a
sunday for 200
or you could fight for a half a million
dollars
they gave the opportunity to fight for
half a million dollars he probably
smoked a joint the day before am i
supposed to be mad at him or whatever
i'm not mad at him
was defined hefty five [ __ ] years
it's his third time
right
it's his third time and it doesn't
really matter if it's hefty i mean he he
must have to sign a contract that says
you know you won't smoke weed whatever
the [ __ ] reason is whether california
whatever the [ __ ] alaska alabama yeah it
doesn't matter regardless that thing
says you can't get high
i know a bunch of you guys would love to
hear yeah [ __ ] yet listen man
you know he's gonna appeal it he'll
probably get it down to two years or two
and a half [ __ ] years but
he broke a [ __ ] rule
he broke it well it's a you know what
it's his third one
if he respect what he did uh mike and i
were talking about this before i love
comedy
if right now tonight what's the guy with
the one ear that just got the [ __ ]
show
steven dorf whatever his [ __ ] name is
stephen colbert whatever's [ __ ] him
tomorrow i got the [ __ ] call they'd
like for you to be on the show i'd have
to turn it down
because i wouldn't represent myself
properly somewhere it'd have to be a
[ __ ]
somewhere would have to be an edgy joke
so if i didn't look at it from that
perspective
so if you came to me to fight for half a
million dollars and i know
deep in my heart i love smoking
marijuana i'll lie to you
i'll tell you i'll stay clean for i'll
give it 10 days
yeah i'm gonna lie to you but after ten
days something's gonna happen i'm gonna
be [ __ ] bored and it's all over
you know and that's me i just know you
have to know yourself i'm not mad at
nick and nick should be everybody should
know this there's rules in the ufc
you're in the top echelon
of your profession
and it doesn't matter like everyone's
saying like oh well we doesn't it it's
it's not a real drug or whatever
that could be the case but if if you and
i were this high in
i don't know what state doesn't have
medical marijuana it doesn't matter on
one of those states and we got ready we
could go to jail
it doesn't matter that it's legal here
and i'm gonna go to jail here too they
can do whatever the [ __ ] they want they
shoot people every [ __ ] name put a
gun in your hand and said you were a
terrorist they'll do whatever the [ __ ]
it takes to clear the [ __ ] murder you
see it on tv eight people beat up a
homeless dude they held them down a
gunman are you [ __ ] kidding me they
gotta call you know so it doesn't matter
right they're gonna come in here right
now and arrest us for that [ __ ]
edible and get us for possession of our
of uh something else it's not marijuana
and edible uh it's something completely
different you get busted one of those
[ __ ] vaping pants it's not marijuana
it's a controlled substance oh jesus so
it becomes something completely [ __ ]
different
so
thank god listen that god that sag
doesn't have urine tests when i go to
shoot a movie or a tv show because i
flunk all of them but i know this going
in
that's the ufc what did he think that he
was going to go in and get a nine month
suspension this is his third one guys
that was anderson's first one
third one
you know what you're telling me when you
[ __ ] it up something like that three
times do you know what message you're
sending me what message are you sending
me mike
i don't really give a [ __ ] yeah
mike you're not at that point mike you
booked lee on the road for six weeks
lee gets there late to three of them
what's he telling you and you got him
good money what's he telling you
i don't want to do this
i'll find somebody
who will i'll find somebody who'll come
here and fight and abide by the [ __ ]
rules
right for half a million [ __ ] dollars
and the frustrating part is
like
mike could just get another
well like the the person
who
isn't gonna fight it can go fight
somewhere else or the promoter can go
get a different fighter but someone in
like mike's position
who
is making money based on a deal
you still like i can't imagine what nick
diaz's
agent or manager or whatever whoever was
was thinking like i have
i don't know let's say it was 500 grand
he was gonna get 50 grand he had 50
grand
fighting on that
and and he doesn't know if his client's
gonna show up at all even and then if he
does you gotta move in he's gonna be
high you gotta move in and handcuff the
[ __ ] if you're getting 50 large
yeah you know you can't just sit back
and go well i thought no
no and this is but you're a big boy yeah
in reality i don't need somebody moving
hey listen
when i was 27 i had a predicament how to
pee in a bottle
have you guys heard the stories of the
[ __ ] i did i used to pull my
uncircumcised dick back
get pool cleaner crush it up like salt
and put it in my dick
and put my uncircumcised dick skin back
over it and then i would pee and pull
the skin back and all the particles from
the pool cleaner would close
and when i failed the next time i used
draynor
i used [ __ ] drano my dick still has
psychological
and [ __ ] meat scars on my dick thank
god nobody ever looks at my dick that's
why when rogan asked him would somebody
would have dated somebody who committed
suicide no but if they suck my dick they
should kill themselves because that's
got drano on it [ __ ] machunga juice
how long were you sitting there with
drano on your dick like an hour two
hours it must have been a while right i
would do it right away so when i went in
there with my dick it would still be in
chunks
because if you knew when you had to take
the test you had an idea i always had to
prepare if i got high on a friday and i
walked back in on a monday with my
record they were going to pee test me
so my job was i wasn't going to come
back clean but i was going to throw that
[ __ ] tester
i was going to blow up the computer the
last one i did was draynor what's the
[ __ ] you put
it was either alka-seltzer or drano and
the guy put it on his desk
okay the guy would walk me into a room
watch me pee with the door open i would
take the bottle pull the skin back pee
and then the drano chunks will fall into
the p i'd cover it give it to him with a
glove on he was walking with it you
could see the pink particles
floating in this [ __ ] thing and they
never caught you he puts it on the table
and the thing starts shaking you could
see the thing
like it was like meth getting made and
he's like so how you doing what are you
doing this weekend because he was like
from somewhere in [ __ ] texas or
something and he doesn't even catch this
three days later i get a [ __ ] call
dog you [ __ ] up the computer down do
you know how long i [ __ ] around with
those piss tests
do you know how bad i was but it didn't
matter
i was put in a halfway house i was
giving rules
i failed one time i had my turn i had to
pay my turn like four grand to go in
there and fight for me to put me in a in
a nun where you go spend the night at a
halfway house where you just go in from
six to nine
and i got away with it and i gave him
another heart
for touching it because then i stopped
snorting but i was still selling it
so i would weigh the chunks and it would
go through your skin so what about so
from nick's perspective you know that
you've had two failed drug tests
you're going to lose 100 whatever grand
and you're going to be in my world i was
going back to prison and i still got
high at least what were you thinking
and a baby were you even thinking about
it or just didn't give a [ __ ]
didn't give a [ __ ] so i understand where
nick is coming from so let me so pretend
i'm your friend back then i'm like hey
joey you you're in the halfway house you
shouldn't do this coke oh i'm not gonna
do it this is gonna be my last night
tonight i'm never gonna do it again i'm
getting my [ __ ] together i only did this
because you called me up and said it was
your birthday i'm only doing this
because of you i'm only getting high
because of you i was home i was gonna
stay home with my manager and write a
script and [ __ ] but you [ __ ] called
me up to dublo now you're [ __ ]
telling me about my daughter what type
of [ __ ] enable are you right away i
ruined the night right away then i go
[ __ ] you and then you go come on don't
be mad i'll buy another ball okay
now i got my hooks in here [ __ ]
i always loved when somebody came and
gave me the [ __ ] whatever right
because i flip it around that's your
addiction
how dare you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i'm
never talking to you again take your
cocaine back i was just kidding
come on keep it all right
so what do you think's in it for diaz
like what does he need
he's gonna appeal it and then [ __ ] uh
hopefully get knocked down to two or two
years couldn't he fight in a different
state though or a different country or
not i don't know what the rules are
i have no idea what the rules are
i think you can maybe wrestle w didn't
they say channel sonnen
maybe
well he's fighting amanda morris i just
saw the headline today
yeah but that's like jiu-jitsu
tournament
there's no striking and [ __ ] i don't
know if he gets yeah i think he gets
paid i don't know what the rules are
they love
he writes a letter or some [ __ ]
they don't test you those tournaments i
don't think they test your metamorphosis
i'm not sure
do not quote me on that i'm a comedian
not a jiu jitsu contest [ __ ] rule
maker are there uh
peds in jiu jitsu
do you think no idea i don't even know
what a [ __ ] ped is like steroids
everybody does steroids except you and
me and this [ __ ] guy over here you
have to assume everybody says [ __ ]
steroids nowadays or some form or
something
remember there's people on anti-aging
stuff
right you know so there's some this
everybody in hollywood wants to live to
a [ __ ] they're a hundred
so if i could sell you a [ __ ] dream
package that you're gonna live to a
hundred come in hairy week i'll shoot
you just keep drinking water and eating
sushi and sushi then and everything will
work out for you you know what i'm
saying whatever lee i don't [ __ ] know
it's [ __ ] it's just um
i mean he must have enough money he must
be doing something else because i was
gonna say it's too bad he's ruining a
career but well i think he trains people
listen they paid him a half a million
dollars
for two or three fights he made some
money they come back
they figured that would get him focused
remember he didn't show up to a [ __ ]
table reading they pulled them off the
fight and they put him up against
somebody else
and i like him i love him and his
brother i'm fans but this is the reality
of it you're at the top echelon of a
league that's getting weirder and
weirder every [ __ ] day right it's
getting weirder and weirder so why are
people even uh well we don't know what
isn't isn't nate not even fighting right
now he's like waiting for a better
contract
i have no idea i wish i [ __ ] knew
how do you
mike how do you
i don't know what the word is
give your advice to a client who
because your money depends on them
making them bringing money in but then
you want them then they're like oh no
i'm fine i want to hold out but then
it's it's tough because you're dealing
with with an addiction right it and like
joey said they're professional liars at
that point but no they'll convince you
and everybody else on on how this is
different and and you know in the comedy
space that happens all the time where
you'll deal with someone and and they'll
have a problem and they'll go to rehab
and they'll come back and like hey
everything's great let's hit the road
let's go let's go tour let's go do this
and and
you got to trust them right i mean
that's your guy and they're telling you
they're telling you hey this is
everything's fine everything's great i
got it together i'm going to meetings
everything's fantastic and they sound
great and then all of a sudden you're
hearing stories about they don't make
radio they got locked into this but then
there's an excuse there's something that
happens oh they fly my flight my alarm
didn't go off and then they're good the
next week and then the week after that
you know something else happens and it's
uh it's very very challenging especially
when you care about these people um
you know joey said there's only so much
you can do you know i mean at the end of
the day
they have to want to help themselves you
know i mean look at look at like this is
a perfect example he had a half a
million dollars uh going for one fight
and he still chose the drug over
over that i mean that's there's nothing
any person can say i mean you could lose
your family you could lose everything
for an addiction and it happens would
you still work with someone who
who's been through a couple failed drug
tests or whatever or or gone like at
what point do you have to say i can't
work with you anymore
it's very tricky
it's uh it's a tough call to have you
know because you feel for them you know
you you're they're they're kind of like
kind of like asking a brother when do
you stop talking your brother you know
he disrespected you time and time again
he hasn't paid you back he hasn't done
this you know it's any kind of addict is
always a tricky situation
uh but there does come to a point for
sure where you're risking your
professional career uh and you're
risking your reputation for for them and
uh there does come a point for sure you
have to kind of have that conversation
go dude i can't do this anymore like
it's it's
i i don't trust you
and once that trust is gone it's very
hard to kind of bring it back but
i don't know man i don't have the answer
on that one that's a tough one i've been
through i've been through some pretty
brutal situations where you know your
heart gets ripped out and and you don't
know what to do
even not even with the drug situation
just
i mean you must have clients who
who
you're trying to guide in certain ways
and maybe the deal doesn't go well and
then then you get fired or or
it just there's so much
it seems like there's so much that isn't
even based on the job
when it comes to
that kind of relationship it's a like a
lot of times it's it's
factors that had nothing it's like it's
like why professional coaches get fired
a lot like they get the blame yeah yeah
it's you know it but it's what you
signed up for i mean you know we're the
last ones to get credit for anything
even though it could be our idea or it
could be you know us pushing you into
something and and then
you know it's always the act kind of
getting getting 100 credit as they
deserve and uh but you're the first one
to get planned anything goes wrong if a
flight gets delayed if a [ __ ] club
doesn't pay you if any of that kind of
stuff you're always the first one to get
to get planned but you know that's part
of the game and i think as long as as
the client knows you're doing the best
you can you know you're always going to
get fired for no reason you're always
going to get
you yelled at for something that had
nothing to do with you that's that's
that's the name of the game you know you
got to develop a really thick skin brass
tacks
since we're on the subject
if i was doing what i did now and doing
blow
we wouldn't be here you and i this would
have been over a while ago especially
those six a.m ones oh yeah
uh this wouldn't happen
my road career would have been done yeah
after 90 days the true colors would have
came out
there's no way there's no way
you have no idea what i went through
from 2004
to 2006. i would cancel the morning of
i'd wake up and still be paranoid from
the night before and there was no way i
was going to the airport
there was no way well well okay joey but
we just saw it there's a four four
there's an 11 o'clock you could still
make it that's not gonna happen
what would your excuse be i got a cold
i got arrested at the airport i lost my
license
you got really really good at making
excuses right you're probably the best
oh it was it was it was and i was really
good at booking myself yeah and at that
time i had in 2005 before the longest
yard came out my phone started ringing
from a couple people they all sucked
they all sucked yeah and then i bumped
into bill burr on the plane and he told
me to call mike berkowitz
that's when they were with a different
company yeah way before apa
and mike berkowitz threw me three weeks
but i knew people so i was booking these
b rooms these sea rooms
get not a bad payday
i wouldn't show up
i wouldn't show up the day out and i
knew it i [ __ ] know it even though
you needed the money
even though i needed the money
i would wake up in the morning look at
the luggage and go
not today so here's a question so so
what is there anything anybody could
have said
to to help you get there is there any
like if you had
you know an agent a manager
is there anything that anybody could
have said on the phone to get you on the
plane to go there you're just there's no
way you're going no no no i don't feel
good i got up i got the flu
i twisted my ankle i went to the airport
and i got arrested yeah there was about
when i had about with paranoia
between the pills they were giving me at
the at the doctors
the coke and what and the years of abuse
i had gone into a different place in my
mind and it was it i didn't really give
a [ __ ] what anybody thought
i really didn't if i woke i remember
calling rogan in the morning and going
call somebody else and him yelling on
the phone for eight minutes of me just
hanging up the phone and unplugging it
it's not gonna happen i'm not going to
the airport i'm too [ __ ] up
i'm too [ __ ] up
and don't get me wrong i got on some
planes [ __ ] up on the way home
oh
oh did you ever not do you ever do that
did you ever add like a place like out
on the road not want to go back to la or
did you always make that flight
i always made that flight in the morning
because i knew it was death except for
the time i bought the 30 valiums in
beaumont texas
and i started eating them on thursday
and by sunday morning i was incoherent
i got picked up monday taken to a hotel
in houston
the club owner of the lap stop
said just go to the intercontinental and
sleep i slept at the intercontinental
from tuesday guys to thursday the
valiums didn't wear off
you figure i had 30 times 10 milligrams
of valium in my system 300 that was 400
[ __ ] pounds
never did i break a sweat only when i
snorted blood i did not drink water i
drank coca-cola straight out of a
[ __ ] can from the beginning of the
morning to the end of the day
that volume was gonna sit in my system
and every time you let a joint to valium
restart it
i remember calling mike berkowitz and
yelling like what the [ __ ] about that
and i couldn't even talk straight still
my face was numb from the blow
and the valley i'm seriously this is how
[ __ ] up i got i went on the road to
get [ __ ] up yeah
like i went on the road to get [ __ ] up
by the time i got to my destination the
packages were ready
the calls were made the night before and
we were going deep
houston dallas el paso miami
buffalo
uh
in fact i was thinking i just call him
to say hello jeff
and myrtle beach
oh yeah i love jeff that's my dog jeff
and his wife at myrtle beach he's your
drug dealer in myrtle beach no he was
the comedy club owner
he made he paid me 500 but i made a
thousand doing fake rentals
what what's a fake round you know when
you sign up
and you sit there and take that you're
beating for their [ __ ] condominium to
sign up and at the end
you get 75 bucks i would sign up for
three of those a day when you get me i
put earplugs on i'd sign whatever the
[ __ ] you want me to sign
it was before 9 11. they weren't
checking ids what are you kidding me i
was joe smith john labamba
they just give you 75 bucks cash 75
bucks cash and they give you a beating
for an hour and a half why you got to
sign up let me go back and talk to my
attorneys
i'm trying to loosen up this building in
manhattan have you seen those signs
around l.a like 99 bucks round trip to
hawaii yeah yes that's what that that's
what that is and apparently because i
just i went to go look i was like what
is that 99 bucks round trip to hawaii
apparently if you go as a couple they'll
go they'll turn to the guy to the girl
and being like white with his loser he's
not going to buy you a time share in
hawaii
and but if you do it you get 99 bucks
round trip airfare
and that's after they [ __ ] take your
car keys and hide them
oh that's a he had beaten and a half
they wouldn't [ __ ] with me do you think
it's worth it
if i if a blow in those days 75 dollars
75 for a packet 75 to get my dick sucked
and 75 for some cocktails
and i still walk out of myrtle beach
with a nickel on [ __ ] sunday night
what are you kidding me
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me i'd get
up early all coked up and go to that
[ __ ] high i like to buy a condom
what's your name what's your present
value i think i'm worth about 80 million
i got a building up
i want to hear your pizza i got a
building i'm trying to move in midtown
manhattan i'm dropping the price from 11
mil to 9.5
but i'd like to buy one of these
timeshares come on in
and i'd sit there in [ __ ] time and
i'd take the area sure 8.9 percentages
i'd be dropping mortgages
international [ __ ] yen [ __ ] rates
and [ __ ]
i get them all confused
and at the end of the day 75 beans cash
and dollar
and then i walk down the block to the
other suckers tell them some [ __ ]
story i'm a chinese immigrant
i got property in hong kong i'm trying
to move them i swear to [ __ ] god i
did this every time i went to myrtle
beach
that's great and they loved it everybody
was like oh and i just told all the
comics and all the comics started
[ __ ] doing it what are you nuts
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with lisa how did you convince them to
give you 75 dollars i didn't convince
them they convinced me yeah but but if
you're like yeah i own
manhattan
listen i went there one christmas the
only time i could work the club is in
the holidays because i was too dirty for
the summer it's too many white turks
jeff loved me i knew jeff from his
milwaukee days
they used to book appleton
that's how long they've been in the
[ __ ] game and his wife she's a
[ __ ] knockout 20 years ago she's
probably still a [ __ ] knockout
and then they said they broke away from
that lady that used to book milwaukee
that controlled that place the gang
placed
the one that belonged to the bikers in
milwaukee
he jd he's gone now six foot nine for
300 pounds paigey there was a gun on the
thing all the doormen had suits uh
triple john gotti suits everybody was a
gangster big family dinner thursday
night
big family dinner he was the vp of like
a big time biker gang well
and the whole the headquarters they've
been on gang land the whole [ __ ]
thing this guy was coming and also owned
the trouble that was their front yeah
the condo looked like something from the
[ __ ] monsters
the furniture was beige
people had come all over it
it was horrible then they also have the
club in appleton the bikers it used to
be bikers that owned appleton also there
were two biker brothers or something
like that this is i'm going back 20
years ago yeah they ran that
the lady kind of went crazy gave the
business to us she also booked marquette
university i remember doing marquette on
tuesday night they booked all that they
went to uh myrtle beach bought a home
and opened up the comedy shack
yeah yeah the comedy whatever the [ __ ]
it is and they're nice people it's just
they're nice clean pee and i'm saying i
go down and get [ __ ] up down there
those bars in the strip the water's warm
everybody plays golf that's the other
thing everybody goes down there goes to
time share and play gum
the question i wanted to ask you mike
that
a lot of comics listen to this podcast
and i remember being a comic in this
town
and you come to town you get made a
regular at the comedy store i was very
fortunate i made a regular month
afterward got here january by february i
was in the store
a week later i got made over at the
improv the guy was a boozer and he liked
me he used to sit in that thing up there
in the little office and just get high
and watch me and one day he was calling
for spots and he started giving me two
spots a week so i was rocking and
rolling jimmy masada didn't like me but
gilbert esquivel booked monday nights
jamie didn't come in on mondays
so gilbert always gave me the 9 25 spot
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
so i was rocking and rolling so right
away you think you're making progress
and there was a company called iag and
i'd walk in there with my manager ken
phillips
ken phillips was a genius
he got fired because he tried to send
faxes on colored paper
he spent 100 of the company's money on
yellow paper
little did he know you know what i'm
saying this guy was really money
ken did you call the [ __ ] guy yeah i
called him he hasn't answered the phone
in three weeks that's funny he just gave
me two weeks
he gave me buffalo miami i don't know
what [ __ ] line you're calling i swear
i've been calling the guy tremendous
yeah
so i had ken
and i had ken call around
and at that time there wasn't a lot of
booking people in 98 you had the wig
richie soups
i don't think innovative was booking no
i don't know who would see it who was
that caa yes
i remember who was that oh
icm had a booker caa had a booker i
don't remember who he was but i remember
the icm booker he's another agent now i
remember that whole thing
and we went through all of them there
was a big booking agent who booked
carlos and somebody else aj jamal and a
bunch of other guys out of i j o i
and everybody passed on me i was [ __ ]
heartbroken
heartbroken hey i'm a funny guy
i'm at the store four nights a week i'm
at the improv too
you know i'm featuring i'm starting the
headline if you sign me now
oh
dj
was over at
the feature factory that was the best
agency at that time if you were a
feature omnipot
because at that time they were really
booking features as headliners and small
clubs they were developing 20 guys which
was [ __ ] genius half of those guys
are still around today in bag
uh i don't even remember the rest of
them but i see it around town but he had
a bunch of guys in those days that we're
really tom
parker tom whatever
no no tom somebody else from south
carolina one in that area he had a bunch
of guys that were really helpful
features and he was grooming them to
headliner for you know and that was the
only agency that did that in those days
either you [ __ ] uh
were wendy liebman
you know or nobody else booked you
i didn't understand why i couldn't
get somebody i got a couple bites during
the longest yarn
but it still wasn't complete
when
is it that a comic needs to start
getting booked
you know
it's tricky
for me
i i'm unique in the fact that i look for
a rock solid hour
and then that's the bare minimum for me
so you know i get all the time
comedians that are very very frustrated
and they they kind of think i don't
understand i kill every single night and
i go yeah you're a professional comedian
that's the the entry level to being a
professional comedian is you should be
able to be very very funny for an hour
now what else do you do do you have the
right look that can get cast in this tv
show it's going to blow up are you
writing screenplays are you
are you doing a podcast are you going
out there and hustling are you figuring
out mailing lists you know someone who's
willing to do the the the work that it
takes you know was different a long time
ago it's different 15 20 years ago when
you just do a tonight show spot
and and all of a sudden your calendar
would be booked for the rest of the year
um
i've had a bunch of comedians that i've
worked with who literally told me exact
story i mean
um
who was uh
who was roseanne's ex-husband
tom arnold tom arnold was telling me a
story he i think he had seven and a half
minutes maybe 10 minutes material he did
one tonight show set and he's he's never
not had to work he's never not worked
from that moment on like he's his
calendar has been full
from the time he did the tonight show
said and that just doesn't exist anymore
i mean there's so many more
opportunities when we're performers
um
so now it really is okay great you're
funny
what more are you doing and i mean i
think
you're the perfect example of of a comic
who was killing every single night
and frustrated instead of
waiting for some rep to come in and save
the day
you took action and you built your own
career
you know i mean look at what you're
doing now you're spending time on a
monday night
most comics right now are are sleeping
you know they're at the store they're
watching netflix they're doing whatever
you're working you're building a career
you're putting your time and you're
putting your effort in and
i think that that always translates
especially now um
so that's what i tend to gravitate
towards you know those comics that are
willing to do okay great you're funny
but what else you know there are other
people that will just chase it okay
you're you're a cute
21 year old girl who's got two minutes
let's see if we can cast you and there
is a business there for for a small time
but really to build a long career i
think it has to be this i think it has
to be effort
to to be able to maintain it you know we
were talking today about earth wind and
fire and
uh their agent was telling me that it's
like i can still put earth wind and fire
at bonnaroo
and they'll walk away with thousands of
new 20 year old fans who had no idea who
burned in the fire was you know they
they still have it they're still willing
to go out there and work and there's no
ego in it they're willing to go take an
opening spot at bonnaroo and just blow
people away
um
you know i just find those to be very
cool interesting stories and a lot of
comics get this ego they get this well
i'm past at the store so i shouldn't
have to do that you know i'm i'm
i'm the funniest guy in kansas city so i
shouldn't have to start over that [ __ ]
that i don't want to do that
um
so there's not really one thing to do
but i would say
you know figure out what you're really
good at on top of just being funny and
use that as a resource you know i mean
you're you're a fantastic storyteller so
the podcast was a perfect medium it was
perfect totally so it's 1995 gentlemen
on maintenance 1995.
i'm doing comedy five years i'm doing
comedy seriously between us at the table
i'm doing comedy with everything i got
for three years at this point the first
two years i was just wasting my time
giving out business cards telling people
i'm a comedian
getting on stage once a month going down
there just to make a drug deal you know
what i will meet you at the coffee shop
i'll go down and do a spot and i swear
to god it was like a part-time thing
yeah then i realized effort has to be
put into this and that's when everything
changed
so it's 1995. this was the formula
this was it i know you're a young guy
lee you're ready for the formula
you come to hollywood
you get passed at the store the improv
of the lab factory you go there every
[ __ ] night you bang it out a manager
was gonna come up to you and eventually
an agent's gonna come up to you it's
that [ __ ] simple in those days they
come up to you give you a card two days
later you were in their office on wall
street they were off in your water and
giving you their spiel and saying you're
that type blah blah blah blah blah blah
didn't you tell me that like people used
to wait at the store with like plane
tickets this was way but this is 20
years before me
i'm talking about 1990
my dream this is what you had to do in
95. you had to come down here do that do
some spots and then you had different
pads a you could either go to tonight's
show path in that day and blast it that
way
or b you'd go to movie path or
there's another path
go to montreal yep the whole thing pad
now here's what happens
let's pretend you don't get you're not a
tonight show guy and you're not a
whatever guy but let's say you bust out
in
six episodes of the holiday show modern
family
this is 1995.
you bust out in six episodes of modern
family out of 13. they used to be 26 13.
you bust out in six in those days your
booking agent came into the store i love
to sign you we'll get you out next week
and in those days and when a comedy club
put from
modern family boom they didn't give a
[ __ ] who the person was that was the
formula if you recurred on one of those
shows then right from that recurring
you'd pop a special comedy central hbo
maybe showtime in those days but it was
that simple that was the [ __ ] formula
that's all it took that's all it took
and then you went from there then you
just got booked into different things
sometimes you laid off sometimes they
just threw you on the road i didn't know
the formula why they threw you on the
road sometimes they threw you on the
road there was big money involved i mean
when i started
the guy with the smile bobby collins
was very hot and that day the genius
wendy from the comedy works in those
days monday night she'd have bobby
collins in there
and she would give him like 10 grand for
two shows because of his search
commercial
a [ __ ] commercial
that you knew he was bobby collins you
know you guys were kids you don't even
[ __ ] remember yeah they were bobby
[ __ ] collins so bobby collins would
come and go high and bobby collins
asserts they keep my teeth right and he
eat a thing and he'd smile bam they put
a [ __ ] flyer up in every city bobby
collins is coming to town from the
[ __ ] search commercial when i got
here there was a commercial there was
two idiots on a mcdonald's commercial
scott something and some guy they got a
mcdonald's commercial where the
celebrities would walk in and they'd
stop him with a hat on that guy was on
the road making [ __ ] money for
[ __ ] ever because you made money from
those things
that [ __ ] don't happen today well isn't
that good in a way
to be honest is it hasn't the quality of
standup gone up in my
it's forced it to for sure i mean it's
you can't really just get by
based on a commercial now people people
figure it out i mean you know dust and
dime is a perfect example of like okay
you can have some fame but people aren't
going to come back the second time in
the third time in the fourth time unless
you got the comedy you have to have a
comedy chart that's where the comedy
chops come in when that little window
opens up yes you better be ready because
if they put you on the road they're
gonna put you on the road for 45 then
that's going to get out and also you're
going to have [ __ ] uh
you know somebody opening up for you
doing 15 just to kill [ __ ] time then
it's 15 and then you're off the [ __ ]
road and that happens that's not
happening today sure but you know that
that's why i always say
you know
once you have that rock an hour then
it's okay what else do you have you know
once you have that because that's not a
career right i mean going on the road
because of a commercial now you might be
able to fill seats or you might you know
if you get a arc on some big tv show
you'll fill seats for the first time in
but those people tell their friends nah
that guy sucks don't go see him um and
you want the opposite you know i'd
rather i'd rather sell 300 tickets a
weekend than 400 tickets a weekend than
800 tickets a weekend you know and build
it that way
then then kind of the reverse pop so
um and then i don't know about you guys
but a couple new year's rob schneider
headlined in boston and i and they
always advertised it as like rob
schneider from deuce bigelow like
whatever whatever movie they were saying
it and even before i was ever into
comedy at all i was like i don't want to
go see him do
deuce bigelow stuff
like it
i think it might turn a lot of people
away well that's what happened i
remember
being in miami and having a feature week
and another feature week and that third
week joe rogan was walking in i'll never
forget this this is big time
and he was joe morelli whatever his
[ __ ] name was
he was there with chris mcguire who's
now a big time writer on all these
little comedy shows
and uh i was there and i said [ __ ] it
i'll stay in mc for you guys
and every night somebody would pull them
over and go i am [ __ ] blown away the
language was awful you should be ashamed
of yourself
and he would go what's the problem you
know i came to see joe gorelli the goofy
guy you know that boxes and stuff
trust me people sucked into that yeah
they thought they were coming to see
that guy listen the longest yard came
out
i remember a distinctive night the guy
now runs the small club in atlanta nice
guy what's his name he runs jamie
he gave me a shot to come into his old
club a big club and i'll never forget
one night i was walking in there
and this lady and her husband and their
friend bought like a table of eight
and they're like oh my god there he is
and they hugged me and they're like
you and i'm sandlin where we love adam
that's why we're here
when i got off stage
i went to pass them they sucked
themselves in
and looked the other way and would not
touch me with their bodies
like they were great they thought i was
going to go on stage and trip yeah yeah
break a guitar around and be like one
that had them sandler's guys and that's
when i realized i gotta find a way
to let these people know
who i am
this was the whole thing that night
always stuck with me and then i went to
see the wrestler
and the reason why i went to see the
wrestler on the first night which how
long we've been hanging out four years
do you ever see me telling you i'm
calling a movie standing on wine i don't
give a [ __ ] every weekend no i'm
wrestling this is all an act wrestler
came out at 11 30. i was there at 11 15
yeah with 80 other people and each of
them were saying i've been waiting for
this movie for eight months so was i and
i started thinking how did people know
about this movie
eight months before it [ __ ] came out
that kept me awake for [ __ ] six
[ __ ] days
i wanted to know how people knew this
was coming out that they leaked it on
youtube because i didn't see it somebody
had told me i went on a computer page
and i saw the
hidden trailer or something like that
that's it
so they didn't promote that the wrestler
was coming out
no what i'm saying is that i knew it was
coming out six months before so it got
me very excited
now you go see a [ __ ] movie it's
coming out two months later we find out
about it right i found out about black
mass when i went to see mad max
that's [ __ ] up right black mask
so it was two months ago right the
wrestler i knew it came out in december
i was talking to somebody about it in
july and they were telling me that he
was training
that this is the [ __ ] movie that it's
a low budget that's why he's going to be
really good make sure i [ __ ] saw it
that that somebody saw a screening of it
and came out crying
that word got out that's a powerful word
remember when you and i had a discussion
about 1975
when we first met we got really high one
day and i gave you chills because i
started telling you about boston and
like aerosmith i started telling you
about marketing i started telling you
about the boston red sox and the boston
bruins and the boston celtics
and and and whatever else was going on
in boston but here's these five little
dirty white dudes
from quincy or wherever the [ __ ] they're
from and they're making the national
headlines there was no twitter there was
no facebook newspapers didn't call other
newspapers
and say do a write-up
word of mouth
was very big i wanted to know how to get
word of mouth because that's the one
that people trust the most of course
is when i look at you in the office and
go go see [ __ ] sebastian that's how
podcasts got promoted that's how i found
out about him
word of mouth there's no advertising for
podcasts i heard the first one the other
day jimmy pardo did one he had like a he
was a spokesman for like autozone and
said listen to whatever his podcast is
but like this the only way i ever found
out about podcast was facebook and then
people in my office
it's it's it's just same thing happens
for comedians right i mean billboard is
a perfect example of that of a guy who
built it just based off of of people
telling their friends you got to listen
to this thing this thing's amazing
and and then putting out quality hours i
mean you're no different you know think
about what what you've built on the road
and
and
but here's the funniest thing and i've
had this discussion with you yeah when
my agent signed me to do comedy
i was doing comedy 20 years
i had an hour just being me but i was
not really a headliner i really wasn't
ready i remember those first couple
weeks i went out yeah i was really
having a rough time with people who had
come to see me from listening to the
podcast they were still like uh this
isn't
it took me a while to flow it
and then i think it was like in kentucky
that when i got off i said oh i'm a
[ __ ] headliner i just balanced these
guys i knew what material hit him with i
was very prepared
but it took me a while and i've been
very honest about it yeah you know i
remember columbus didn't hire me for a
long time and i said that's because i
bombed last time i was there there were
people there
but i didn't do that well i didn't do
that i didn't feel like i had done a
good hour we we talked about tv shows
and movies
what was it like for you as a comedian
after doing the rogan podcast
one or two times like what
like what was the reaction like well
okay so i'm in this [ __ ] town
i got the coloring book for a theatrical
agent
ever tell you about that no the coloring
book was my first
theatrical agent
is that the name of an agency first i
signed with a manager i met him at the
improv he was managing carrot top and he
left they all left that company they
were at and opened up different offices
across the country they all got a
severance package and they all left he
took his money came out here bought a
brand new car a few suits
got some cards some rings on and started
[ __ ] peddling management he signed
myself but he went towards black axe but
i tell you who was what they we did find
gary owen
he signed gary owen out of the navy
but as soon as he signed gary and that's
the thing
the guy worked for me minimally with
gary owen he took him right gary owen
and him were making money right from the
beginning then he got married and
something happened with the chick and
his father said you ain't making no
money i can't keep giving you money
and he flew him back to north carolina
or something like that but
i remember we sent packages out together
and at that time i had a pilot at cbs
did you know that no i was showing up in
an envelope
i wasn't just showing up like some
schmuck with a headshot i was showing up
with an envelope and a minimal thing but
i was showing up with a cbs [ __ ] deal
all you had to do was call and close it
and you had me the coloring book
a black agency in the in the
it's not a black yes it was it was two
black chicks
and it was one chick that was a badass
attorney like this [ __ ] just caught
people and they would tremble because
her husband was somebody
and the other chick was an attorney and
they both went to georgetown this was no
joke
listen man this chick worked for me she
didn't [ __ ] around but i was in an
agency called the coloring book their
resume
i always had i have pink ones or yellow
ones but yeah it was [ __ ] ridiculous
sbv signed me which at the time was a
huge commercial agency when you'd walk
into sbv
you were somebody what they had muffins
people called you mr diaz
you could walk into the back and get
your checky poos
they had christmas parties back then
thanksgiving parties all the clients
would come down and eat mingle having
been to a [ __ ] agency christmas party
in 12 [ __ ] years those things got
shut the [ __ ] down this time
okay so i showed up with a pilot
a little bit of money
the coloring book [ __ ] signed me
then i booked basketball
i liked the coloring book but it's i'm a
comedian i got to be with apa
doug stanhope's an apa everybody's at
apa i'm at the [ __ ] coloring book
the count the comedy store kept saying
giving us a headshot i couldn't because
it said the coloring book on the bottom
i couldn't [ __ ] do it
do you understand the struggle i went
through so now i booked those two things
after basketball
then the taco bell commercial i started
knocking on doors
and still
still with the coloring book go [ __ ]
your mother go [ __ ] yourself it was
brutal
but then i booked telemundo and i got
after
i booked the show on telemundo for a
thousand bucks i went down there and i
was a cuban doorman
i booked it
in those days you had after and sag i
was after
it's the hottest spanish show on
telemundo about cubans a cuban american
family and burbank
and it shoots in burbank i [ __ ] go up
there dog report on time rehearse
they go alright let's go eat lunch i'm
in my car the phone [ __ ] ring the
pager goes off i go call they fire me
they just didn't like my spanish they
didn't like me at all
they were two different listeners so
what are they there's jungle cubans and
there's decent cuban i'm a jungle cuban
because i [ __ ] knocked the audition
out of the hotel but it didn't matter
they paid me and they paid for my after
who's better than uncle joe
you understand me so i'm cooking with
gas i'm figuring i'm gonna do something
guess what show becomes the hottest show
on tv the sopranos now everybody's doing
soprano spots guess what boom mad tv got
a sketch i get up at [ __ ] nine
o'clock cooked up to the gills i got 19
messages every [ __ ] agent friend
assistant
comic that got breakdowns that was the
big thing call me up joey just don't i
walked the [ __ ] mad tv you know
walked in there my head shot people were
looking at me just before 9 11.
people were looking at me like what's
this kid doing in here and all of a
sudden what's the black guy that does
the impersonations
he saw me
and he used to see me at the store but
always just wave at this moment harry
spears harry spears came home he goes
what are you doing here dawg you hear
from my [ __ ] soprano scratch oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and he grabbed me i walked and
they were auditioning piano players or
whatever magicians
he got me right to the front of the line
i went in and knocked the pants off i
got that once i got mad tv i started
talking a little [ __ ] yeah i had to
start dropping names and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
nothingly
see you then jamie
pop the show
are you expecting everything yourself
with this all myself okay jamie kennedy
pops the hottest show on tv the hottest
reality hidden camera show guess what
the producers live in my building
they're doing the mafia one they deliver
pizza again i'm on tv because the show
got so hot and they didn't order another
13 so they kept playing our episode
people kept coming up to me at the store
oh my god i saw you i'm calling apa i'm
calling [ __ ] dea
ppp they're all telling me to go [ __ ]
myself i'm out there every afternoon on
wilshire spending 15 in the park
dropping envelopes dropping names on
people then [ __ ] them nobody would talk
to me then i got the denero movie
then i really started dropping [ __ ]
names analyzed that
still nothing but i thought by analyze
that
at least i would start selling tickets
nothing
so what i had been told
to do
three years earlier i was doing
and now i wasn't getting
do you guys follow me i'm not throwing a
pity party here i'm just telling you
what my reality was
that i was attaining the goals i was
told to attain that i would start
[ __ ] blossoming
nothing it didn't my cousin went to
ithaca film school right at the end of
tape
and it wore all went to digital and he
wasn't in the industry so it sounds like
you just at the end
of an of an era sort of
it just it's uh
i guess it kind of hurt you but not
really who the [ __ ] no
boom
nbc is doing a show about
a family
of lawyers
now i'm first i'm gonna pilot i'm a
bartender in the pilot
a cbs [ __ ] show that
it was supposed to go up against nypd
blue
they had paid the director a million
dollars an episode to [ __ ] do the
[ __ ] show it's going to go on for
sure it gets canceled
you have no idea like you get like i was
going to and i was going what the [ __ ]
is going on here yeah all these people
at the store popping deals and their
shows are getting put on i pop a [ __ ]
cbs pilot and i'm gonna be like an eight
out of twelve
and now i'm [ __ ] they're not doing it
then i booked this other pilot on nbc
about six lawyers that lived in the
house i was going to be a recurring
maintenance man dog and i find the pound
i'm a plumber
and i'm fixing the pipes and what do i
find in the walls 30 pounds a pot
so now i'm part of a conspiracy it's
bellafonte's daughter
and it's somebody else's son the show
comes out of the [ __ ] gate it's gonna
blow up i'm in episode six
eight nine and ten somebody else
was making a comeback i still see him
around town he was in episode six
eight nine 12 and 13. we're all waiting
to be big stars the show gets cancelled
episode five please
god suckers
now i'm st so
it was just weird that the evolution of
this [ __ ] thing like i did all then
the longest yard let's cut through this
i came out with spider-man 2. then the
longest shard the longest shards started
getting me people but i let him
sandler's name
and they would come in and run out of
there like i was godzilla
and i'm not lying there was no pictures
then nobody wanted to take pictures
they'd come over ask me questions about
adam sandler
but i wasn't gonna trust me i used to
read this thing people were like [ __ ]
that guy
he's up there rapping on stage and you
could see shit's coming out of his nose
and
it was horrible so anyone who came to
your show
was like the club giving away tickets or
just randomly the only place i sold
tickets at that time
was houston texas
houston texas had a tremendous comedy
scene and they supported up and coming
guys
babbitt was the genius of bringing
hedberg and i'll never forget like
hedberg was just starting to blow up
and the kid had just lost his show on
nbc but he was still funny as hell in
fact i called him today
tom
we were at the store that night
tom rhodes
and one day i'm talking to batman he was
i'm bringing tom rhodes in here with
mitch hedberg to call headline
that's like ali at the time and [ __ ]
joe frazier coming to your [ __ ] bar
and having a drink where you're in
snorting blow
i never heard that before doug stanhope
taped the cd there rogan taped the cd so
people would just come there on the
strength of the [ __ ] club and if you
drank on stage and were getting [ __ ]
up you were selling out
wow so you you people would come back
for you every every time you went yeah
in houston i started building a market
but then the club went out of business
and everything fell apart in these
which was good because i started staying
in moon focusing on film
but it's just weird that
this whole thing started the reality of
this podcast thing for me
this thing started
on the rogan podcast
and then went on beauty and the beast
when i told the story about mugging the
hooker yeah when i went down to that
comedy club that night and there was 100
people there
and the owner called me and said he goes
you know there's a hundred people here
on a sunday night
and they paid and i'm like he [ __ ]
he paid me my money he gave me a door
deal and everything i was blown away
this all started so this was why
this is the weirdest thing ever
but i never thought i'd get booked or
never thought but this all started by
just telling people
stories and telling them the truth and
that's it you know embarrassing
you know you mugged somebody or that you
went to jail you know how embarrassing
that is did you did you just
how different is your your set
now versus when the longest yard and all
those things oh my god
all right the longest shot i've been
doing comedy now
for
13 years or something like that 91 91 is
nine
and five is 14.
i was at the store
i was following good people but i was
just telling jokes
you know what i'm saying yeah just go up
there do you remember any of
them they were so bad
they were so bad then whitney cummings
directed produced a special
about five or six years ago when whitney
started getting big
she blew up she produced a series on
showtime
about comedians
short-lived six episodes
i don't even remember who was on except
one particular guy
and i was doing coke in my bathroom with
the door open listening
taking a [ __ ]
just doing little bumps my wife was out
whatever and i'm doing little bumps she
wasn't my wife at the time
listening to this guy and that's when i
realized how bad i was
i knew i had to do something different
with my act
because he had the same sort of he's not
around normal
so i was correct
he's doing something completely
different now but me listening to that
guy i was like me and him are a lot to
say
this is horrible
this is rodney watered down
doing something else you know i'm saying
it was just really weird
and then i just at the time i was
writing stories
and one night i popped one of them on
stage and i realized how intense i had
the people
i had the people locked in somewhere
where my comedy had never locked people
in before had you prepared the story or
just you went into it i wrote the story
like two days before and i was on stage
dying somewhere
as usual i was on stage just [ __ ]
dying somewhere like a flapper
and i busted a story and i saw the
effect
and then ari
something happened and i went down to
the improv and it was marc maron way
before the [ __ ] show guys yeah
the podcast was just getting started
maybe a year and a year and a half maybe
two years and i went down to the improv
because ari was gonna do a show about
telling stories it's a pink floyd story
right the painful but here's the beauty
of it
and this is us family because i'll tell
you mother and you know it do you think
when i drove there i was gonna tell the
[ __ ] pink floyd story i don't know
what the [ __ ] do you think as my [ __ ]
jew brother here i'm rosh hashanah a big
shout out to all the jews that are
listening right now you know you're my
people deep down inside [ __ ] these
gentiles when this [ __ ] is over i'm
going to israel with you [ __ ]
understand me and that's between us
don't tell these other people [ __ ] that
listen to me you didn't i don't think
you knew until you started i don't think
you might not have even known until you
started saying something to my daughter
mercy diaz that when i walked into that
improv that night i was telling a story
about something
completely different
and somebody was up there and they said
something i go wait a second what am i
gonna go up there with that [ __ ] for
i'm just going to go off the cuff
on the [ __ ] stupid pink floyd night
with lubes and joe focaraccio and
and that's what happened
and somebody sent it to me
and i i don't want to watch that [ __ ]
and then somebody put it on myspace or
one of those it was that long ago yeah
and we clicked on one day i was high and
i watched the first two minutes
and i gotta tell you i was blown away i
was embarrassed i turned it off
but i couldn't believe how i was saying
the story and i had [ __ ] up at places
i know i told like he was a marine i had
[ __ ] up at places but i still told the
story so how long have you been doing
comedy the way you're doing comedy now
this year five years that's it four
years
but the last year has been something
completely different once i went back to
the store so right around the time we
met that's crazy that lit the fire under
my ass
i'm a different comic than when i
started hanging out with you than what i
am today so that that's interesting
right if you think about that
and you are i mean what you're doing on
stage right now is brilliant it's um
it's not brilliant it's completely it's
completely [ __ ] different i think a
lot of people think it's brilliant
it's very very funny let's put it that
way um but that's a good that's a good
thing to kind of bring up right i mean
you had these things you had these tv
shows you had you had the longest yard
but but there was a reason that people
weren't
coming after it right there's a reason
and i think it was because of what
you're doing on stage you know and if
you look at what what's happened to you
i i hear so many comedians that just go
i
you know i should be out there hustling
i should be talking to agents more i
should be you know sending my my demo
reels or my head shots to william morris
or any of these things
and
and i can't i keep telling them like
guys there's a lot of people who get
paid
a good amount of money
to go find you
there's they will find you and i was
just saying how often like he was joey
was saying he sends out he sent out a
lot of resumes
how often every week how many
submissions do you think an average
agency gets thousands oh my gosh so many
and i feel so bad i mean it's such a
waste of
of money and time and resources and and
this is
you know what joey and i were kind of
talking about you know we wish you could
just tell these communities like just
focus on your craft like trust when the
time is right we will find you that mike
a conversation you and i had yes because
you and i don't lie to each other and i
don't know why the lead now let me tell
you the other side of this story
this is where opportunity meets whatever
joe rogan's my brother i've been running
with joe since 1998 since news radio
when [ __ ] fear factor premiered i was
in new york with him he bought a samurai
on 48th street who stops in new york
city
and what
listen to me [ __ ]
okay before well the summer of fear
factor we're walking down manhattan he's
there to announce it i'm gonna go do
some other [ __ ] work job
but he calls me goes come with me keep
me company let's go i'll pay for that go
[ __ ] yeah let's go to new york what the
[ __ ] we're walking down broadway
he's in a store buying a samurai
on the [ __ ] thing
it's fear factor with his picture like a
samurai sword a samurai like some some
statue of a [ __ ] character
that his eyes would blink okay he's in
there going joey you gotta look at this
[ __ ] thing and i'm in my mind where
you putting this because what do you
mean when i'm putting this on my front
door
the eyes will glow at night i'm figuring
if i can put eyes on it so anyway i go
outside i got a page i got three
thousand in my pocket but i stole from
the maid when she wasn't looking like
that's how broke i am do you understand
like seriously i'm telling you guys the
truth
but sopranos is the hottest show
here's joe rogan
talking to me on broadway with his
billboard flashing on 42nd street but
people asking me for my [ __ ]
autograph because they think i'm a big
[ __ ]
how [ __ ] crazy is that
that's funny now here's let's let's talk
about joe joe was on news radio he went
out there for peanuts there were times
they were calling for a replacement gig
and he would lose money on the plane
ticket and what they were paying them in
the beginning and people coming out to
see him from news radio and there was
like a year lapse
once he got on fear factor
people started coming out by the droves
and i guarantee like a lot of other
people a lot of people left there very
disappointed they thought it was going
to be a quirky host they ran into a good
comic and somebody who talks about
politics on icebergs and
rocket ships and is very intelligent as
material but he kept half that audience
and then when that show ended he did
something else then he got the ufc and
he's built that he's built that audience
over the [ __ ] years now i've known
joe since 98. i've opened for joe in
every [ __ ] improv in the country
but guess what
guess what guys
i did something that i did not know i
was doing that i heard somebody else was
doing i heard that dane cook answered
people
but all of a sudden dan cook became a
star on myspace
and all of a sudden against my will you
know me i didn't even want to text
at that time i didn't even i was the
last one to hold out for a [ __ ] cell
phone i didn't go for the cell phone
until 94 baby i'm not gonna lie to know
but i held on to that red page that
thing went underwater that thing had
blow on it acid
i had minerals i shoved it up to chase
[ __ ] that that blow that pager was gold
every time i went out with joe
i would do blow and i'd go back to my
room
even when i lived on schrader and i'd
and people go friend you
and said we saw you at joe's show
this is eight years ago and i would
friend those people
and say thank you for coming out
all those people i friended i guarantee
10 percent is still lingering around
some way or another
because i had the opportunity to go on
the road with a guy that was drawing
more than i could ever ever in my life
dream but i would always prepare those
sets
this is my chance to go this is the
all-star game and i got a [ __ ] chance
at bat these people don't know i've been
to prison these people don't know about
addictions these people don't know i
cancelled planes
one time i left my luggage and walked
out of the airport and got arrested at
lax i was so paranoid on cocaine from
the night before i got no reason to lie
to nobody in this room
and here i'm getting a shot
there were nights i go to the comedy
store lee i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
saying
but when i would do those joe rogan sets
i would sit down while they were out
doing push-ups and [ __ ] and they thought
i was in my room doing blow i was
writing the craziest [ __ ] i was gonna
write in my life and say
and guess what out of those 1200 people
i made 30 of those people my [ __ ]
people that now listen to the podcast
to understand me i was very intelligent
and when they moved to facebook they
came with me to facebook now i answer
them
and now they came to twitter
and i know comics gets sent messages on
twitter guess what i'll answer them if i
see the [ __ ] thing i'll talk to you
back and forth if i'm on there rocking
and rolling if somebody says they came
to the show they bought tickets ask them
i say thank you and i'll see you there
that's an extra move so over the years
that gift that's that's the gift that i
didn't do before
i thought oh i'm on a tv show
call the [ __ ] club
you know call life cm tell me joe diaz
got 40 of these on a tv show no
i had to work it from the other end yeah
where's [ __ ] tony bennett what are we
here there looking at me
big [ __ ] mic in the house
tonight we saw yeah how you feeling
buddy you want to eat this little purple
dot this last it's only 10 milligrams
i've had 325 milliliters
stop stop lying i'm not lying show the
rappers
all of a sudden the rappers don't have
labels on them
the one i do doesn't use labels this
ain't the one i do i bought this from
the russians see you're giving all the
information that's not yours to give out
white on the one i drew into this
conspiracy
why are you throwing the one i do into
this [ __ ] conspiracy
gotta get some carted somewhere well you
can't mention he's at home right now
[ __ ] smoking opium getting this dick
sucked with a bagel
dude you know whatever the [ __ ] they eat
on new year's they felt the fish the
[ __ ] white fish
whatever the [ __ ] they eat anyway you
know i love you jewish people happy new
year to you and hope it's a better new
year and you make more [ __ ] money you
take over
we'll start a little neighborhood in
cuba we'll [ __ ] rendezvous in havana
what's up ball sniffer you felt good
today didn't you uncle joey took you at
10 in the morning you rolled around men
sweating on you they choked you
did it today was like the day the first
day i did the elliptical i went home and
i just felt i just fell asleep good you
deserved i couldn't i did [ __ ] great
today he was sweating he was drenched
it was stuck
with my leg no i ain't coming i stuck
that little [ __ ] auschwitz foot
right in my [ __ ] leg i had him with a
hannah
and the half guard and he [ __ ] put
his toe in there and broke the [ __ ]
half guard he's his toe got right in
there he has one of those little jute
toes what did he say like the foot that
kicked jesus or something
remember the whole judicial class
you got the foot to kick
you know how we do it yeah you
that's yours i'm telling you i have an
uncle he was there when they were
kicking jesus
the little jew feet
you could tell when they related to
somebody who was kicking jesus
pontius pilate went around and got
people like with feet like you
he said we are going to do a good job
people okay jesus when i come up with
that one
i don't know jesus christ but it was fun
i'm really liking the small class and
then nick we had him on the podcast he
was one of the guys who did the stick
fighting sure he's [ __ ] crazy
and
it's uh you're looking
around your hair's growing
[ __ ] propecia you're doing this i think
that when i was young like 12 or 14 but
then they came out with the it had like
the side effects of we stopped what are
the side effects
you can't get a hard on [ __ ] that you
could always get that little stubby
heart and [ __ ]
a little still
what does that say to you
no i'm not falling asleep i'm [ __ ]
going to say something to him i had a
brain fart that happened this time of
the night
i mean
now in this market today
let's be honest
beside the chelsea handler people who
were talking
it's very tough
to just be on tv and attract people and
i know hunzie he's one of them that's
been on tv he's got a couple specials
but it's transferred it's over now it's
over to the internet people do that
like the vine stars and youtube stars
are doing that
they just have you seen like the like
right at the freaking comedy store that
youtube guy has a billboard
on that hotel
i don't know so i think that's what it's
transferred to
yeah but even that's very difficult i
mean it's it's very very hard to break
through um
you have to be great you know to to be
able to really sell tickets
you have to be if you want to do it for
the long term i mean you can have a pop
people people that are mediocre they
come up with some kind of catchy video
or some song or some bit that blows up
but
in order to maintain it you have to be
great you have to constantly work and
you got to be you'll be doing exactly
what you're doing you got to be at the
store
at the laugh factory you know the comedy
cellar at the stand in new york i mean
you know you have to be at these places
constantly riding and and you know
really taking that approach of doing a
new hour every every year and a half
something like that every time you're
here
mike
it's about evolving exactly you know i
go out sometimes i'm embarrassed i got
white [ __ ] head
and i'm standing next to 25 year olds i
could be their uncle two times yeah you
know what i'm saying
and it's you're embarrassed you're like
what the [ __ ] are they coming here for
what don't they know
don't they have an idea and in this what
we're doing now
you have to open up yourself listen
a great example
last comic stand
first three or four seasons
everybody who was associated with the
show
did great the ones who stayed out there
were the ones that had been doing comedy
for a while right and even then you know
ralphie may's a great example when was
he in the last comic standing 22 [ __ ]
years ago he's still out there banging
out there's reasons for that he was
always a great comic when he got on
there he was just at his
real peak of busting the [ __ ] out there
so he's built that fan base over the
[ __ ] years
but a lot of them you don't even hear
from no more there's very few of them
now like the only the only is a few that
i can think of and i love those guys i
had tons of friends that were on that
[ __ ] well not even eliza selection
joe was a witness she's still out there
banging that yeah who else felipe uh our
buddy the black dude
that moved to arizona came back he's
hosting the show now alonzo bowden
okay was a finalist rich voss is still
out there from time to time
torturing people i love that
[ __ ] i see him in the store and
he was leaving
i wish we could get him on the podcast
for some laps
there's still a lot of guys that
maintain because
a
at the end of the day when you go on a
friday night these guys deliver
i've always believed in you know you
come to the [ __ ] show
listen
i'm not gonna lie to anybody in this
[ __ ] room i wish i was still a
feature act
i wish i could go into a club
let lee do 10 minutes
the bartender comes over slips a package
in my hand i give him 40 bucks i put it
in my top pocket in case the cops come
the emcee does 10 minutes
guess what uncle joey goes up there
does 30 minutes of material and 22
so they don't stop [ __ ] laughing
i get off the stage thursday night i do
a couple bumps i'm out of there it's off
me
it's off me guys i don't give a [ __ ]
what happens the rest of the night
you think i'd give a [ __ ] if that guy
could follow me and that after a while
after a while i learned that i was part
of a show
right but i was a feature for [ __ ]
you know 18 19 [ __ ] years
i know how to [ __ ] feature you want
me to do 30 minutes i'll do [ __ ] 24.
watch you better open up the [ __ ]
door
because i'm going to come out of there
like a barracuda i got nothing to lose
i got i just go straight and i get the
[ __ ] off stage and i go get my dick
sucked and do a blow once you become a
headliner it's a complete different
responsibility i wish i could still go
out and do 20 minutes and not give a
[ __ ] whether they laugh
don't laugh drink don't drink i don't
give a [ __ ]
but to become a headliner take something
else now you have to start caring about
them
even when i went on the road as a
headliner for years do you think i gave
a [ __ ] about them i'm only going to do
blood
i'll give a [ __ ] about these people they
like me or not i'm getting a paycheck
the part-time that he's mexican he's
already got his cousin over here on a
bicycle
you know what i'm saying i got sleeping
pills in the room and this little
waitress says she likes to party
you think i'm worried about these people
i'm not even gonna come back here next
year i'm going to be on a tv show next
year that's what i would tell myself
[ __ ] these people
but for me to go out every week and
maintain it i got to fall in love with
the audience
i got to keep writing and i got to keep
evolving listen some people could write
really fast some people can't
i know if i give you a quick 20 take a
picture with you and give you a hug
we're straight
we're straight we have a good time we
laugh next time you see me i have a new
[ __ ] 40. that's just the way life the
[ __ ] is maybe not maybe i have a new
hour ten
if you know me i'll have an hour ten but
who the [ __ ] knows yeah if it's a year
later most of it will be new did you see
that uh kevin hart just filmed this
special at eagle stadium
well
yeah
you know when i went out with joe rogan
mike over here told me a story about
kevin hart tell them what happened with
kevin hart
tell them what happened with kevin hunt
i'm going to equate it to what i do with
rogue and tell him
it was such a great you know the way he
built that whole thing he talks about on
the marin podcast
and
i want to say with soul playing one of
these big movies that he had that just
kind of came out and he thought that was
going to be it and done that and it just
tanked it just didn't do anything for it
and he calls his agent at the time and
he goes put me in every single club i
don't care how much money i make every
week i want to be on the road every
single week
and
and he goes tell him to just fill the
room just comp it out fill i want every
[ __ ] seat
packed and
and i'm going to turn those people into
my people
so you go to the houston improv or
whatever and he'd go just feel it i
don't care who they are look if they've
ever heard of me or whatever i'm going
to put on such a good show
and that they're going to become my
people
and and he would kill it and he did you
know you'd have three or four hundred
people in the audience that wouldn't
know who he was they just signed up for
you know a free ticket for something
let's go to a comedy show great this guy
has a he you know him from soul playing
you know he had enough credits that
people would come in and see him
and
and he would sit there after every show
with a clipboard
and he would just get email addresses
from every single show
and you know it turned in from 2000 a
weekend to whatever it was to 5 000 and
he started building that audience and he
kept doing it on time time and time and
time again kept writing kebriding
capricorn hustling gustling and uh and
built it
and basically got to the place where
where he could go to a studio and say
hey uh if you want my fans that i now
control and i i talk to on a regular
basis you're going to pay me whatever it
is a million dollars a movie i don't
know how much money he makes a movie but
i would imagine it's probably around you
know a couple million bucks a movie and
and he did that because he built it all
himself no different than than what
you're doing or what you know dan cook
did at the time and
i think that's a good story for every
comic to sit there and go okay instead
of waiting for hollywood to come around
instead of waiting for the right role to
come around i mean this was his role i
mean that movie was supposed to be
everything and instead of just sitting
there and bitching and whining he goes
put me on the road let's go let's go hit
it and and he created his own
opportunity
and he did it by working his ass off and
and
that's something that every comedian out
there can do and it's one of those
things
you know i hear it all the time where
you know like oh man i'm killing i'm
killing i don't understand and it's like
okay but are you talking these people
you go you go play a club
i've been the best story joe i think i
told you this uh uh my roommate at the
time was a while ago um he started
dating through check and
this girl goes oh i've never been to a
comedy show and i go great go to the
improv you know tell him my name and
you'll be fine i'll take care of you the
whole thing and she calls me afterwards
and she goes that was one of the best
nights of my life and she's given me the
headliners materials she's telling me
these stories and the jokes and the
whole thing
and she's like i love this guy he was so
funny and i go that's great who was it
and she goes i don't know his name i
forgot his name but he was so funny
and i go oh my god jo jo this is what's
happening to so many these comics out
there they're going out there and you
know they're they're they're being funny
but they're not doing anything they're
not talking they're not going out i mean
all those little tiny things that you
can do they're not collecting an email
address they're not they're not putting
out an album i mean you know one of the
things i keep trying to kind of educate
people on is you know we should be
giving this audience things every single
time so if you're if you really are that
funny as a comic if you really are that
great
you know go record an album for 300
bucks and give it away to people in a
chance for an email address you know
give them a podcast every single week
where you can you know you can show your
point of view
and go out there and do it there's no
need with how easy it is to do this
there's no need to sit back and wait for
hollywood to find you
you know it just doesn't make any sense
and that's just not a way to make a
living
you're waiting for some casting director
to decide you know whether your eyebrows
fit this role or not
that that's i don't know it's a
completely different game it's a
complete mike it's a complete
different game i went to a place today
and i know the girls are actress and she
works
and okay you know i'm an old man i don't
expect to go out every week
this girl not only is she young she's a
[ __ ] knockout because i haven't been
under four months she told me the agency
that big time agent four months she
hasn't been
to an audition
yeah
things aren't what they used to be
anymore
you know they have too many different
markets where they're shooting i don't
know i don't know what here's the beauty
right so is she what is she doing and
this this is always my kind of question
okay is she
is she going to the ucb is she going to
growlings is she going to acting classes
and doing the right things is she doing
internet sketches with with her friends
is she is she doing funny or dive videos
to be seen out there i mean there's
always something that she that somebody
could be doing right maybe she is and
she's not getting love but if you really
are that talented
and
and you really are capable of booking
something
it'll come you just got to put yourself
out there
you know that's the one that i've never
i've never seen anybody that's that
funny that hasn't gotten you see what
happened last week but what that check
with the fat shaming video right yes
okay
let's draw it on the table
you know what her mistake was
she'd have a podcast
if i put that video up next week nobody
would say boo because i'm a [ __ ] fat
guy and what i'm telling what she was
saying she made great points i'm not
going to say didn't tell you she didn't
make me but the way she did it
so let's say
the way she did it if she would have had
a following that would have went a
completely different way if she would
have internet big time found i don't
know how many hits the video got maybe i
don't know what i'm talking about well
what do you think would have happened if
like because her her thing is she's
skinny she's making she's being mean to
fat people like let's say you were
making fun of like it was a racist thing
do you think it would still be okay if
she did it and if you did it like i'm
trying to think of the equal amount of
like it's got to come up it's got to
come up with somewhere
now so what you're going to do now she's
going to go on the road from that video
you think somebody called do you think
[ __ ] you no no
no i don't think she called her and said
we're taking it on the [ __ ] road
we're going to get 10 percent of the
hits on you i haven't actually seen it
but i've heard it's not that funny
it's edited
so that's where you lose me yeah when
you're a comic throw that [ __ ]
and uncle joey yeah me and lee tape i
[ __ ] up we start from scratch
that's why you do comedy
that's why you guys
well they're all comedians
and that's what people have that's what
gets under my skin
not only am i comedian i've done comedy
in buffalo and a bus theater and a bus
station in auburn
there used to be a bus station in albany
that
yoder used to [ __ ] book what
a bus station on my thursday night by
the lockers you gotta go give me a
couple of minutes yeah what like where
where would you do comedy the best
inside there was a bar
okay and you would spend the night in
albany like down the corner of the hotel
[ __ ] craziness and then you went to
buffalo
and then the guy that used to bug
buffalo was rob liedeman at the time
and he had a bar and at the time there
was a uh there was a bar in north
tonawanda that was uh
it wasn't maybe not but i know that this
rob lederman's bar the comedy place was
in north tonwanda and he would pack it
in that bro
he would pack it in that mic i mean
friday thursday friday saturday with
nobody yoda people 800 a week
pack them in 20 at the door eat pizza
the guy had a scam guess what he did in
the daytime
he was on the radio in buffalo
so the place was always [ __ ] sold out
because he had a free advertisement free
avatar he was the man don't forget to
come down tonight he had you on the
radio friday morning and thursday
morning if you came up but
he would
you have to
when you you guys know you're from small
towns right when you're going to a barn
and the celtics are in the game for the
playoffs guess what
who gives a [ __ ] about a comedian
they'll turn you off i don't give a [ __ ]
if it's jesus i'm making a comeback with
the apostles and they're gonna play a
song and you're the first one to hear it
with the stones you know you're from
buffalo and i remember i had to go up
there in halftime
like that was what happened he we came
in and he was like listen guys i got bad
news for you guys there ain't no show
there's a saber game my bad i'm still
gonna pay you but do me a favor at
halftime ichis go up and do 15 minutes
lee you have no idea what i learned that
night
you have no idea what i learned that how
was the crowd
not receptive to comedy
were they throwing stuff at you
two minutes away lee
but i remember standing there at the
back of the room and going i'm not sure
about this comedy thing
we've actually just moved to jersey and
do some coke i'm on the east coast i
just take the bus to jersey right now
what year was that
97
so right before you moved here i was
living here already
i was living here already and i was
taking buses from toronto canada
to buffalo to albany to syracuse
the club in the [ __ ] hotel
i was there with wise guys and then it
became the magician
what the club from the guy it sank and
the magician bought it so he'd open up
the club he was a good magician though
and he gave you a bottle of vodka when
he got to an eight ball nice little
place on saturday
on saturday the city was locked down
even subway was closed because it was
downtown syracuse at the time
nothing was open it was like going to
those commercials and citibank hello
hello out there like i am legend yeah
that's how it was jesus i went all the
way down then i would go to like albany
those small towns
i'd do
roger paul's rascals and the other place
they have a one-nighter up in nyack or
something or they used to up that way
then he had a two night oh at the bottom
of a hindu hotel and he got 15 off at
the restaurant it was [ __ ] brutal
what's a hindu hotel just a hindu hotel
a hotel home by hindus and the
downstairs just smells like curry and
it's next to a gas station that's it
that's it i remember ralphie when he
broke the bed he left on a friday night
come on dog
i took buses i lived on a greyhound and
went from el paso
all the way up to toronto and back and
then i would get a yoda gig do
wisconsin
michigan
so this is kind of like the point if you
think about it so you're making work for
those gigs like how much would you get
for like a gig like that 75 dollars a
night 125 if i headline 175 if i [ __ ]
happy rosh hashanah judah so like
someone like mike would get
at most 15 bucks i didn't have an agent
no and that's the other reason a lot of
comments they wouldn't make money go to
mike and go mike i'm funny i'm on the
road with [ __ ] johnny bananas okay so
what are we going to do with you
well put me on the road for how much
i can't book eddie murphy
for three million dollars
at madison square garden on new year's
[ __ ] morning
because billy joel was doing the night
show
and then called the funny bone to book
joey diaz for
a 600 feature spot
that's 60 dollars
yeah but they could do it because i was
one of those guys i would beg richie
super come on richie call get me in
there's a feature
sixty dollars what are you gonna do with
sixty dollars
four four weeks a month
sixty dollars that's 240 and yeah what
are you gonna do with 240. yeah it's
crazy you know it's it's something that
most comedians don't don't realize and
that's the bottom line at the end of the
[ __ ] absolutely that's the bottom
line that that 1500 you know if you
don't know typically like a comedy club
will pay the lowest fee they'll
typically go like 1500 bucks 12 the
funny bones five six years goes off of
me
way before i met my booking manager i
got a call one day for 12
for wednesday through sunday yeah and i
this is a true story and then i bumped
into
billy gardell
and a diner in burbank
and he was kind of bummed down he said
he had to cancel two gigs because they
had just called him and cut his money
this is way before mike and molly yeah
and he goes they cut his money what the
[ __ ] is going on i'm like oh listen
i'll do it for 12 but there's no sunday
in your world and how much budget for a
plane ticket they said plane ticket is
including the 12. i was like so for 900
i got to fly to your beautiful city and
do
thursday friday saturday sunday and i
just quit i said i'm not doing that and
like three months later billy gardel got
mike and molly now he's opening up a
[ __ ] pizza
yeah yeah yeah gardel brothers or some
[ __ ] but that's the thing right that's
the bottom that that entry level spot is
the most competitive spot in comedy and
that's what you know most comedians
don't don't realize and so many people
that i talk to
they just go oh well can you just make
some phone calls and go in there and you
go dude you understand that spot
there's so many comedians that want it
there's so many more comics out there
that that can kill for an hour that can
make fifteen hundred to two thousand
dollars
that that's the most competitive spot
and yet you make no money as an agent or
a manager or or or whoever um
and it takes it actually takes more
effort and more work to book that spot
than it would to book the spot where
sixty thousand dollars
you know six sixty thousand when you're
making six thousand dollars in one pop
and that's why we have to be so
selective with who we get behind and and
it's very because it's very difficult
and and
there's no payout for years and i would
imagine like it doesn't look good for
you to if you're trying to book the 60
000 deals to also be calling them for
the 600 600 deal like you kind of have
to you know it does if if if if that
person's great you know if that person
is that good
where the club owner is going to go holy
crap this guy's unreal
um yeah that that part does look good
but if if you're in the business of
trying to get people
1500 or 2000 weekends um well that's the
majority of your business you can't
survive no because you need like
10 clients
constantly out there to make any sort of
living
yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] work it's a
lot of work that's a lot of [ __ ] work
10 guys
1500 100 that's 600 a month from each
guy right yeah 600 a [ __ ] month you
got 10 guys
what's that
six thousand six thousand so i guess you
could do five guys maybe by the way it's
it's also like impossible to get those
spots so
you're basically asking a club to lose
money
because you think this guy's that great
but then again you have chris rock yes
so now
here's [ __ ] joe's crab check in
bonefield mississippi and you call him
to talk to [ __ ]
lisa
who's this lee sayak guy well he's been
on conan o'brien he's been on the
sugarless show he's been on jimmy fallon
yeah but i don't know who the [ __ ] he is
does he sell tickets listen
let me ask you something
chris rock
his schedule just fell out i might have
a way for you in december
i'll get them bottom right do me a favor
put this lisa i had in your [ __ ] club
give him two thousand dollars it's like
i used to do to the chinese guy you
promised now you always got chris
rockwell what happened to chris brown
he got a movie with [ __ ] eddie murphy
with me i'll call you next week and now
you you know what i'm saying that you
just milked the [ __ ] i mean
there's a thousand ways to get the guy
in i remember
an expression called the guaranteed
feature
when i was in a feature act somebody
came to me once i'm a guaranteed
featuring what's that mean that
all the comedy clubs have to pay me 600
a week because
uh
rich
miller
said so so rich miller would call other
clubs and that was a good way to get
other talent from other areas you know
but for the most part you know let me
tell you something
600 for a feature act today
it's not even that
i won't name the clubs there's clubs
that just pay you for the sets now as a
feature they don't put you up with
five sets 100 a set that's 500 bucks
let's say you [ __ ] unless you tipped
up through the [ __ ] tulips how did
you get there
even if you drove you got to knock a
deuce off of that now let's pretend
you're lisa yeah you go on that site
what site do you go on
let's go with hot wire hot wire you got
a hotel for 30 a [ __ ] night that's
four nights that's another buck 20. what
do you got left with to do comedy you
really gotta love doing comedy yeah you
could schlub cds and t-shirts but you're
still not the [ __ ] headliner
right you're still not that well how
many t-shirts are you gonna sell
four six seven for the weekend
if you have a cd for five bucks you'll
sell [ __ ] 10 or 15 of those
but then it's like
i got very lucky
when i met you
because i've had people say like why
don't you start doing this with other
comedians
and i think it's very similar with
agents
if they're at a point where they're
making money and they're successful they
probably have that person
and
that means you have to go with people
who have who don't have a a following
yet and aren't making money so it's
and then for the people who do make the
first like the first jump at you like
those first agents then as soon as you
start making money or as soon as as the
artist starts making money they they
jump to a bigger agency but here's the
bottom [ __ ] line we say that yes and
this is a lot of comics do not realize
that mike will push and he'll stand
behind me 100
i can't do it by myself
he knows
for me to keep growing the other side's
got to do the work but i got to cover my
[ __ ] spread
the first time he has to call me and say
joey i just got a call from
[ __ ] bum [ __ ] indiana you're not
tweeting the dates i don't feel like
twitting the dates joey what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] it's not your contract but
it's a gentleman thing you want to sell
tickets you want to hit you follow me
right
it's those little [ __ ] things i have
to stay up on my game in today's world
in today's economy with comedy and all
the [ __ ] free
uh media that's out there i don't even
know if i'm sound [ __ ] stoned all the
free entertainment that because look
my our biggest audience right now
are nine to five people so now people
are gonna go on their computer put this
on put the [ __ ] earplugs on and type
letters to communists and [ __ ] listen
to this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i mean that
that's basically the [ __ ] that's our
biggest market right
so it's not tv it's not
no no the podcasting
is definitely now the biggest
draw i'll tell you before he signs a
client what's their prerequisite right
now in today's [ __ ]
what's the first thing you thought well
the first thing obviously is you know
how how how strong is the hour um and
then and then it's okay well what else
is there you know is it is it the
podcast is it the social media following
is it i mean i i don't see a reason why
every comic should not have a podcast i
i i at this point i don't understand
yeah i it would be hard to convince me
why why it doesn't make sense have a
podcast there's only three louie
kevin and gabriel other than that i
don't i can't think of any big ones that
don't
yes maybe sarah silverman i don't know
if she does
sarah does not but i think a lot of
those guys don't have to they and they
came up in a time that that was
necessary it wasn't necessary um things
work differently for people and that's
different paths and everybody
listen the most important thing about
this game is that opportunity is there
it's what you do with it i have like i
said i got to open up for joe i got to
meet a lot of people through [ __ ] joe
i took advantage of those numbers when
they wrote on twitter i wrote them back
i would go to milwaukee with joe
he'd sell out 2 000 seats the next
morning guess who my phone call was to
i didn't give a [ __ ] what time it was my
agent to say hey
i opened for joe last night and there
was 200 people in there call milwaukee
the first [ __ ] thing you do today
but i don't understand because there was
20 200 people
even if i [ __ ] get 20 percent
i got a show
i got a weekend they're gonna pay
right yeah okay that's the [ __ ]
mentality i got there i got an
opportunity and i did my 20 minutes
kevin hart was brilliant
that was brilliant calling your agent
going get me whatever i want to go out
there
they're going to put 2 000 seats in in a
weekend 1600 at an improv
and if you get
50 percent of that there's 800
now you got something now plus that 800
four more hundred are gonna come so now
you got 1200 now you got a small theater
or a great weekend at a [ __ ] comedy
club now the next time you come you get
another
500 attached to that now you got 1800 in
five [ __ ] years that's the patience
and you probably didn't have to give
away free tickets after the first year
no he just told you the [ __ ] story
after the first year first time i saw
sheryl crow they were giving away
tickets album dropped the next time i
paid 20 something [ __ ] dollars let me
give you some shout outs should we get
this guy out of here he's got to get
back on the phone and [ __ ] hustle
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] rosh hashanah when you
make call there's a real jews are on the
phone most user at home eating salami
right now hahaha waiting for gabriel to
open the door don't they leave the door
open for some [ __ ] spirit real jews
on the phone jehovah not gabriel all
right whatever his [ __ ] name is tim
hoelfer gabriel jason brazile
kevin zoll matthew olivares
gitch from clifton
richard richard payne
andrew nandiao you know i love you
[ __ ] thank you for going for the
doctor maddie's world steve zo
and dj dora or something whatever dj
ding i don't know what the [ __ ] your
name is i don't know what you do for a
living you know i'm not in the mood to
get into it right now
all right this weekend we're in vegas
saturday night shooting the special
next weekend new york city at gotham's
in the week after that the toledo
[ __ ] funny bone go on their website
for infos and times don't be bothering
me with those [ __ ] questions all
right
what lee what's the problem you don't
want to eat this last stop no i don't
right now there's a kid in africa who
flies in the [ __ ] corner thirsty as
[ __ ] and if i go whatever the stone
tongue you're gonna make him more
thirsty no i wouldn't i said thirsty as
[ __ ] right now there's a thc
killer right now would you eat this
right now and i'll bring you a steak in
an hour he will eat this and you're
turning this down this is what i gotta
deal with yeah but you're not gonna
bring me a stick in there or you always
say what do you wanna eat a milkshake we
never gonna get milkshakes because you
told me that you're counting your points
and god forbid that the wife finds out
we're eating milkshakes then i gotta get
a [ __ ] ear beaten i don't need this
aggravation of my life i'm trying to put
[ __ ] together here
you are are doing a great job with the
what you do
thanks man i i wish i i wish i could be
more helpful i'm not sure
is there any other questions you think
that uh that comedians could uh well
even
just from because joey always tells me
i'm going to be a manager
yeah and
it just it's a hard thing to
to know like he we were talking the
other day he said you're going gonna
start like contacting people and and
start presenting yourself but it's hard
to know
how to do that and like what level of
comedian to go for and then
it's um
it's crazy how you were talking earlier
how you don't get a lot of the credit
but it sounds like some managers and
agents do guide careers
and it's kind it's like a lot to
to even think about where would i even
start you and i might both know that
there's
uh bad agents great managers bad
managers
but they are managers and agents that
have
have done a great job and giving great
clients great uh advice over the [ __ ]
years that's good and bad there's people
who know more than others more people in
the game you know
a couple years ago a comedian
wasn't doing too well
and
he
thought he'd [ __ ] do some [ __ ] and he
started doing some [ __ ] with some tubes
and a microphone
and also he put him on itunes
and people started paying attention to
him a little bit and also he went to
this [ __ ] big time manager he had and
he said hey
i got this going on the manager goes
and he fired the manager and the guy
went on to be a big star
my point being that
this manager wasn't in charge wasn't in
tune with the future
the future is upon us and people are not
prepared for us these agencies are
really not prepared yeah zach doesn't
know how to handle the commercials on
youtube
and
people don't know what's going on nobody
really knows what's going on eventually
the hammer is going to [ __ ] come down
and somebody is going gonna is gonna
know what to go on
that's where you come in
you sat here across with me when we were
getting 300 downloads on this thing with
no sponsors you sat there across me when
we shot a documentary
you sat there now we're going to do a
special we've done videos together this
is what the involvement is you could go
to a comedian and go this is for what
i've done right now
this is what you let me get a water over
there you got me over here [ __ ] like
a swami but that's another thing i've
been thinking about though and that's
another one when i talk to people ask me
questions about podcasts
i think a big reason that we've had
success together
is because we've done all that and
because for the first two months we hung
out we didn't even do it we just hung
out
that's not only i don't know if that's
possible
if you want to have
a group of clients i think if you're
looking at a comic
and you're thinking of
giving him the keys to the kingdom
showing him a way
to become
something
but there's also a bargain to that he's
got to keep writing he's got to send
emails he's got to take pictures he's
going to send out [ __ ] yarmulke he's
got to cover all his bases eventually
he'll find his knack what avenues to
work
and both he has worked together right
it's not like you could change
somebody's life right now because
they're going to want to call you in the
morning go so what video do i shoot
today what am i doing telling you you
got to go well you put up a video two
weeks ago let that get 300 more hits
then we'll get you follow me there's a
lot of little things that people do not
know strategies and right now when you
sign a client when you go to montreal
and you see a client they're 26
you know what man
i could see this [ __ ] guy
in
that [ __ ] gotham city he's got a
[ __ ] up eye
i know one of the writers and he told me
you know what let me talk to you let me
just see who talks to him first
you sit down or something bubba boggles
bubble boggles and finally you go over
and creep them like a savage and you pop
up on then you talk but right on the
spot before you go out go up to him you
have to have a plan
of what your plan is listen i know
dickie wilkins he's one of the head
writers on gotham he's looking for a
character like you
why don't we get together on tuesday for
lunch as a matter of fact if he's smart
the agent he doesn't really want to sign
him
he sees something that nobody else sees
he heard that
cbs is doing something with creepy
people this guy looks kind of creepy
this joey d is guy let me see if we can
get him in the cemetery show whatever
the [ __ ] this is before six feet under
you were at lunch with some [ __ ]
schlupp and he says they're doing a show
about creepy people on cemeteries
you signed this kid
i saw it done with somebody in this town
i saw a [ __ ] guy go to montreal sign
this black kid black kid was shy
if maybe
this is 1998 if maybe the kid had six
minutes of material that's all he had he
took him to a popular club shot for six
minutes took him to cbs got him a deal
blah blah blah put dreads in his head
the kids shot steroids one day i'm
watching usa there he is the psych
ticket to anthony michael hall on one of
those [ __ ] shows guy did 18 years on
the sitcom he's back in the bahamas he
took the dreads off he's back in [ __ ]
chicago you know
counting [ __ ] dollar bills he had a
plan right but then he had a plan maybe
this is a question for mike then but
as an agent or a manager to know what
the plan has because not every comedians
are the weirdest people in the world and
the joey's not like steve simone and
steve simon's not like ari
and to know where to guide them if if
you if i if i try to go to another
comedian and do what joe and i have done
it might work but
it might not fit their personality just
right and it fails yes so
what i've been thinking about is that
you really have to get
with somebody
and go out with them for two months
hang out with them and just know them at
the end of the day you know what mike's
job is
in today's society and today's
is to pour gasoline on a little fire
for example whoever did the job with ari
shafir
they poured gasoline on a little fire it
started with a storyteller show and the
fire spread like what's going on in
fresno right now
okay
i'm not making fun of nobody i'm just
telling you the truth
they started with a cell
ari is a terrorist
it started with a [ __ ] storyteller
show for five hours in the back room
army hadn't done a [ __ ] commercial in
22 [ __ ] years
his commercial career was done he knew
that he was always out of town
i don't know
i don't want to go down to 200 south la
brea there's a nice sandwich shop
against the street i don't know i'm
tired i was at the start till four in
the morning last night i'm blowing it
off [ __ ] i'm not even calling up and
[ __ ] he said he would walk into
auditions look at the date and if he's
gonna be out of town for the call back
it i'm not going in there you know go in
there book it they'll change the dates
they'll work something
but
but he's had an idea
and it was just so now
his agent had to go in there and just a
little droplets of gasoline on it and
then spread more keep spreading gasoline
and hopefully that [ __ ] ignite will
get over there that was hari shafir we
all saw it happen in front of our
[ __ ] eyes we saw the show go from the
[ __ ] improv dungeon
didn't even sell serve alcohol back
there
to you know thursday nights at 11
o'clock on comedy essential and they got
good numbers they wouldn't be shooting
season [ __ ] two right now don't
people smoke up nobody's [ __ ] ass i
wasn't like oh well
what do you think should we vote on army
all right let's go out and get drunk and
throw dice against the wall no
so [ __ ]
it was a great [ __ ] idea they flamed
a little firely
yes i do believe you should start a
personal relationship with him for two
or three months and get to know this
person you're about to invest a bunch of
[ __ ] time
once once mike signs you you gotta get
on the phone and start licking stamps
and calling people
and now i gotta send him
joey did i tell you i [ __ ] made it to
number one in canada and i thought
email me that please
yeah that relationship really matters
and i think you know we
you just you just gotta like figure it
out you know that's the beauty of it the
same way you did this right you got
together with somebody you kind of
brainstorm you failed a bunch of times
you figured oh this is how to not do
this anymore okay great now we can
figure out how to do it
and
and it's just years and years of just
putting in the time but but not you know
on a saturday you're spending four hours
with them trying to figure it out
instead of
watching tv you know i mean those are
the kind of things that that
that will make you i don't know end up
building being able to figure out what
those moves are and
look no one has all the answers it's
just it's a matter of experience right
it's a matter of failing a ton i mean
you could go out with your relationships
right now you could go out and run you
know take over a night on a tuesday in
north hollywood of big wangs and tell
them to do a comedy night and you could
put seven comics up there and you could
see who kills it and you could promote
it on the podcast and you could probably
sell it out every single night you could
have the hottest room
in la and then you could build a podcast
you know area based off of that you
could build a little network based off
okay who kills on my tuesday night show
great i'm going to do that
i'm going to get that guy's own podcast
and i'm going to build it from there and
you could have your own little
management company based out of the
valley that could be very very
successful uh doing nothing really
different than what you're doing right
now
and it's just a matter of you doing it
versus talking about i mean that's
that's really the difference okay so
well first of all you might be a genius
but
okay
so how if i
the the comedians i get to meet are
usually
medium to higher level yes
if i invite them to my show they might
do it
but i can't i'm not going to convince
them come to the flying g management car
like it's so it would have to be the
smaller comics like that's first of all
you're a jew you're showing up on a
limbo
you're showing up with somebody already
in your [ __ ] pocket there's a lot of
people that don't want to work man
there's a lot of people that that's the
other hand totally okay they don't want
to show you know the people you've said
we've discussed this where
he was 20 minutes late again the third
week in a row he doesn't really want to
do a [ __ ] podcast
this is uh something else to him
you know we put time into this we
discuss it we call each other i torment
you i ask you stupid questions
we get high together
sorry that's a really good i'm just
thinking about your ideas those
it's a great idea yeah i think you
should also start a podcast to teach
people how to podcast uh i mean look at
all this equipment stuff in here it's
amazing and the trial and error that
you've gone through could save people
tons and tons yeah i've been doing the
consulting but then i'm trying to do i
was thinking of doing a paid course but
yeah maybe i'll just do a free one i
would just do it and say [ __ ] i mean and
do it as a podcast and
you're a smart man
that's why he's sitting where he's at
that's why he never signed me as an
agent he's a smart man we always kept a
friendly relationship
i call him up when i'm in a bind i got a
question
that's why he's on the podcast because i
always
i know this comic sitting at home going
what's my next move yeah there's a ton
of comments i bump onto on the road that
are [ __ ] hilarious
they're [ __ ] hilarious they got it
they're on to something
you could tell you've been there you
know what it's like when you're clicking
you're giving the headliner a little
trouble
people are clapping for you a certain
way and they're stuck they're scared
they ask you what do when i move to la
what happens
and some people come out man go to the
store do three sets
and three arts is there or icm is there
or innovative is there whatever the [ __ ]
is that
and there's other people who go to the
[ __ ] coloring book
and they bang it out for [ __ ] day one
that's just all it really is
you know it's not giving up but the
funny thing is that everybody gets an
agent thinks that day is made
they don't think that's where the work
starts
when i first signed with sbv
i would only bring them eight headshots
at a time they would submit those eight
hep shots every week
they would ask me why do you [ __ ]
bring us headshots instead of bringing
us a bunch
i'd say because i'm not doing nothing
with my day and i want you to remember
me every [ __ ] week
every week at walking test bv into the
things there was a box that said joey
cook or diaz and i put eight head shots
leave and i come back every monday
second thing i did every [ __ ] monday
and from there i went to the coloring
book and talked to them for 20 minutes
about whatever the hot movie was or
whatever i didn't give a [ __ ] i didn't
want them to ever forget me then i
hooked up with pablo francisco for a
weekend and he told me you're doing it
all wrong you got to take your agent to
a strip club
and then i'll offer some coke and get
them all invested and [ __ ] up that's
how you get them to work for you and i'm
like i don't know about that one i don't
like [ __ ] strip clubs i gotta walk in
there with a [ __ ] guy he could be a
part-time [ __ ] racist or a rapist
whatever the [ __ ] he is a racist i swear
to god i had an agent
a theatrical agent that i would sell a
pound of wheat
once a month because he was selling weed
but on the weekends he would rent
himself out and go to these little city
towns and do talent pageants and then
[ __ ] the 18 year olds and come back and
show me the pictures
[ __ ] this guy was an agent and with
the suit the whole [ __ ] thing i mean
it was just
lee okay you're into zomboville yeah
let's do the [ __ ] sponsors and get
the [ __ ] out of here
september 14th
2015.
two more days
it's the 33rd anniversary when i rob the
jewelry store
i always light a candle like that i was
thinking about that i knew it was a
[ __ ] up we let a candle for the
jewelry store sure for everybody
involved you never know you ever think
you're calling him up and apologizing no
just talking to him because like like
it's been 33 years
i still got some james
listen you're thinking of quitting
smoking wherever you're allowed to hang
out
you could you can't smoke you could
smoke an e-cig stop the [ __ ] horizon
right now hit these things
what what's the matter lee
let it
hey these things are the best
e-cigarette out there in the market
right now 1200 guaranteed [ __ ]
pups you're not gonna get that for
[ __ ] what you got these little stores
and [ __ ] like this and it tastes
tremendous if you're thinking of
quitting they got them in 24 16 and
eight milligrams and the cigar is just a
[ __ ] cigar the beauty about this
thing is i've had this like [ __ ] two
months
are you kidding me or what it's like
smoking a [ __ ] cohen blowing
smoke in their face and [ __ ] anyway go
to the hidey cig right now they got a
special deal what's the deal e5
for cincuenta for 50 [ __ ] dollars
10 apiece 1200 guaranteed buffs you'll
be smoking e-cigarettes for the rest of
the [ __ ] year and the beginning of
2016. go to heely6.com right now and
press in
press them welly
leave press
joey's church and get five for 50 beans
all right
number two you know who i love on it
staying on it again shroom type today
lee didn't want to take his i took mine
i asked you if you wanted some shrimp
technically you told me no you were
scared your little fat heart was beating
the ghee was making you hot and [ __ ]
he almost died anyway go down because
you didn't take the shroom tech anyway
go to honda.com right now and look at
the great selection of products they
have
from alpha brain the complete earth
grown nootropic to the to the t razor
the testosterone powder to the to the
the to the mct
oh i'm sorry i'm a loss of words tonight
but listen do me a favor stop [ __ ]
around and i'll stop [ __ ] around go
to hunter.com right now go look at the
great selection of products they have
read up read up i guarantee it's going
to blow your mind my favorite is the
hemp protein the cocoa [ __ ]
tremendous 16 grams of scoop two scoops
32 grams that's what the body
assimilates forget about it you throw a
[ __ ] banana in there some coconut
milk who's better than you
stop it go to honor.com right now and
check out all the great selection of
products
pick one anyone and start your life
living correctly they even got blenders
they got everything i could only get
your 10 off from the supplements i can't
do them beyond the weights and all the
other stuff so go to honda.com right now
and press in church boom there you go
and get 10 percent off your first
daughter tell him uncle joey sent you
and also
my main [ __ ] my cousins from
west new york new jersey
nailed it life.com if you smoke vapor
pens they got the premier vapor pen on
the [ __ ] market go to
nailbitlife.com right now they got a
great selection they always have the
goomies her models available only in
california so don't break my balls guys
they don't ship they're not going to
send them to you can you listen to the
show they don't give a frenchman's [ __ ]
go to those goomies and models right now
nailed it live dot com free the goomies
are models or what else they got the
little chocolate those caught up bars
that are [ __ ] delicious i put 10
pounds on that weekend i ate two of them
delicious anyway go to nail the live dot
com right now and press enter joey diaz
boom and get 20 off your vapor pen
lifetime guarantee something [ __ ] up
you called my man peter boom he gets a
ship to you overnight no [ __ ] around
big shout out to on it e6 86.com nailed
it life my main men mike for coming out
lisa you're a beautiful man
thank you buddy don't forget this
saturday night i'm taping the special
i'll be there friday too and sunday if
you don't want to hang out if you want
to come out leo be there eating some
anarchy edibles some stars of death
next week i'm in nyc
and the week after that i'm in toledo
ohio at the funny bone all right get the
steak and shake ready i won't be listen
that's your [ __ ] you're going to be
at this taking so i'm not going to go to
the floor
no i don't go i can't go no more because
i got to watch my friends
[ __ ] stop it why are you throwing me
under the bus you know i walked past
that thing like a [ __ ]
like a
victim walking past the police station
anyway i love you guys don't forget
about me mike
thank you for stopping by you know we
got to do it this way because that's the
way things are he's a good man i want
him just to come on and simplify things
for people
thanks guys
that's it thanks that's it that's it
that's all you got for your uncle joey
don't contact me and
leave me alone yeah i wish i had you
know i'm not i'm not a comedian
obviously but um
i think it's great you know the lack of
the lack of
you know
what's the way to put it i think there's
a million books on on how to make it a
music business and how to write a script
and how to do this there's really no
information um for communions and it's a
shame because so much time is wasted
away from you know
writing or
performing or that you know spent on
sending [ __ ] submissions to agencies
and going out and getting headshots and
doing all this stuff that doesn't matter
i went to a show the other day and there
was an awful awful show and at the last
10 minutes of the show
after his closer he stands up there and
and the guy goes look uh the only way
i'm going to be able to get nader and
her manager is if i i get a you know
larger social media following they tell
me this this is what you know people are
telling me like comedy central all these
guys and he does this whole ten minute
thing after his set he stands on stage
doesn't walk off doesn't do anything
there's this whole you know plays the
victim and everyone i need to do this so
if anybody can just pull out their phone
right now and follow me on twitter it
would really help me you know move along
and joey i just it was just like i wish
somebody could talk to this guy and go
dude you're wasting your time uh you
know focus on what matters focus on on
being very very funny and then people
will find you
um
yeah
you know ari speaking of ari already has
an amazing
speech that he gives to young comedians
um that's on youtube
google uh goal ari shafir comedy store
he goes in the comedy store just talks
about it and you know the big things
that he talks about constantly write and
just be in the scene you got to be in la
or new york
you got to be just hanging out wednesday
night's the big industry show at the
improv just be there be there every
wednesday and people will recognize you
and they'll see you and they'll become
friends with them and you'll you'll get
to know some agents you'll get to know
some managers people get to know you
and
and things will happen things will
change you know so uh i hope i i hope
that was helpful any uh
any other questions or anything that you
have
let me know i'm here
that's it lee's going to start lee's
going to start his management company
next week i think his weekly show big
wings gonna be the hottest show in l.a
gentlemen thank you so much thank you
very much i appreciate it some questions
brother of course what song we end them
with
hmm
good together i don't know who do ciao
by jimi hendrix what the [ __ ] he's
slippingly you should have known this
morning until he didn't tell me to like
i told you 10 minutes ago that was about
the chat you didn't hear what i was
saying
the [ __ ] thing i'm doing here
the good one from the album don't [ __ ]
around with lives and
remakes and last time you put on like a
a cover band i almost fell off my chair
you blew my doors off where is it i'm
looking for the for the album version
what are you looking for
it's all live
it can't be all live
gotta be something on there you know we
are [ __ ] what he's saying put studio
in there i did that bam there you go
oh no this is life god damn it
that's all right play it live we'll be
your wait night okay just find something
all right